so the long-term trends I think you're
actually predictable in that sense of we
can see where they have been going and
they will tend to go in that direction
but the specifics are not at all
predictable so the genres are the
species are not so an example would be
the quadruped ed form it's kind of
inevitable there's going to be then
because that's the form in animal life
there's many many forms of quadrupeds
those are predictable but the zebra is
not okay and so in the same sense you
could say telephones are inevitable if
you make wires electricity you're going
to make a telephone system but the
iPhone is not predictable it's
completely contingent the internet was
inevitable but Twitter was not the
Internet was inevitable but the kind of
Internet that we could make or want to
make we have a choice in whether it's
international national commercial or
non-commercial those are all choices
that we had they make a lot of
difference to us and they are not
inevitable so I'm talking about the
larger scale trends the the the more of
the biases built into this that are
leaning in certain directions and those
directions I think are important because
they are the main drivers and we can
expect them and we can prepare for them
and they are going to do the large-scale
genre of forms
[Music]